snapshots of a Ukrainian offensive
against Russian forces in the south
this strike hit a key bridge in Herson
city which is under Russian control
gunfire also heard during the day
evidence of the operation caught on
videos posted on social media this place
a key prize for Ukraine to win back
attacks two on the nearby town of Nova
kakovka also held by Russian forces a
local resident who fled the occupation
still has family in the town she
described what they told her was going
on but asked to be anonymous because of
security fears
um
Ukrainian sources said the offensive is
being launched from different directions
including here the city of quivery about
a hundred miles north of her son
the top civilian official in charge of
military operations in the city showed a
piece of shrapnel from a Russian missile
that hit the previous day
[Music]
um
the Ukrainian side isn't giving much
away and access to the front line is
being heavily restricted but the UK's
defense Ministry said several Ukrainian
brigades had increased artillery strikes
on Russian positions in the South but
it's not going to be easy with Russia
having reinforced its presence in recent
weeks if as it seems this is the start
of a sustained Ukrainian offensive it
could Mark the biggest test for both
sides since Russian forces were defeated
in their attempt to take keys back in
March
in a war that's about information as
much as it's about military formations
Ukraine is using all means possible to
intimidate
debraham Sky News in southern Ukraine